Budapest Hungary is an architectural gem
built from the union of three cities and
nothing symbolizes this union better
than its one-of-a-kind Parliament built
to celebrate a millennia of Hungary's
existence perched elegantly on the east
bank of the Danube River the Hungarian
Parliament building is an example of
neo-gothic architecture with some
Renaissance and Baroque elements
commissioned in 1880 it was finally
completed 24 years later its 314 feet
tall an 880 feet long making it one of
the largest Parliament buildings in the
world it said that over a thousand
people were involved in its construction
during which 40 million bricks half a
million precious stones and 88 pounds of
gold were used the inside is home to
Hungary's National Assembly the
legislative branch of the country the
rest of the buildings ten courtyards and
hundreds of offices are all linked
through a system of endless corridors
and a red carpet which is nearly two
miles long one of the highlights is the
nation's crown worn by about 50 rulers
the first of which reigned in the 12th
century and like the treasures inside
the building itself shines like a jewel
in this nation's skyline
you